our region has suffered for so long
hosting the world cup will give hope to
the youth across the region
and making the lasting contribution to
the world
the impact of such sport event
is not limited to fun
but goes far beyond that
to achieve mutual understanding between
different cultures
and different backgrounds
the people of qatar
and the region are excited to showcase
our hospitality
and the ancient culture of the arab
world
the qatar 2022 fifa world cup
is a journey of hard work determination
and tireless effort
i'm looking forward to welcoming you all
in qatar later this year
i wish the best for all teams
participating
and
we have
one of the best
goalkeepers in the world mandy here and
he's going to be
[Applause]
he's going be uh playing against my
national team so
i spoke to him earlier i told him that
you know
i hope he's not gonna be in the best
shape during that game
thank you very much all the best
[Applause]
sorry hello
okay
thank you thank you his highness and uh
it's such a great honor
to have you with us and
thank you for those uh encouraging words
we we had a brief discussion earlier
and
mandy who is
one of the best goalkeeper said he's
going to play very
hard but of course we want qatar
to proceed and do well president kagame
so wonderful to see you so good to see
you and also a special thanks to klaus
and the world economic forum
for providing this platform
this is a
a relaxed
easy session
and we're going to keep it as informal
as possible
the
approximately november december this
year
5 billion people worldwide
will be watching
the qatar
fifa world cup 2022
it's it's a great privilege and a great
honor
for
not only for the middle east but i can
tell you for the developing world and
and for football all over the world
that uh
the world cup is coming to qatar we
cannot think
of a better place or a better
personification
his highness you spoke about trust and
you have built
under your visionary leadership so much
compassion so much
love for people not only in the region
but worldwide and we are immensely
grateful and this is going to be the
best
fifa world cup ever we've got no doubt
about that
the
other issue is that
football has shown us over many years
in a very unique way that it brings
people together
from different language groups different
races
different religious
backgrounds it it has served as a
unifying force
i was in nigeria last week to hand over
the confederations cup
and
the leadership there both in football
and in
in government were saying when the
national team of nigeria plays
all of the ethnic
backgrounds becomes one
united
nigerian
come together all of the religious
backgrounds
unite because in those 90 minutes
the nigerian national team represents
the best of nigeria i've heard the same
being said in
cordova and i've heard the same in many
parts of the world
we also know that when
if you talk about a different spot when
pakistan and india play cricket
for that time
we've been told over and over again
the the soldiers on both sides
both pakistan and india stop
and and they watch cricket
they watch sport so sport brings people
together and of course
football
is unique and and has played the
greatest role in uniting people across
the board so we're going to start
and one of the things we're going to do
is to
also recognize
the the fundamental contribution of
football to the socio-economic
upliftment i mean
every time i'm in qatar
i see thousands of people from all over
the world
having the privilege and the excitement
of employment and taking money home with
the building of the stadiums the
building of the hotels
the the benefits and the impacts
of
the world cup in qatar
far surpasses
the huge infrastructure that's taking
place in qatar but it has huge benefits
for our people in the middle east as
well as worldwide
so uh
we are now going to start
with uh the president i mean there's a
whole we've got a world-class team here
and i don't need to take too much time
introducing them except to say that
we have
the president of of uh fifa the
president of football worldwide gianni
infantino i mean you've done exceptional
work since you've taken over to focus on
making sure that that the respect the
ethics the credibility
in in football all over the world as
well as in fifa is is reinstated and
you've done excellent work keep up that
work ronaldo who's called the phenomena
has won the world cup twice
and scored a huge amount of goals during
all world cups
and one of the exciting things is
football inspires young
boys and girls all over the world
not only to become like ronaldo
like mandy
but also to use the success and the
inspiration of those football stars to
pursue their talents whether it's to
become a doctor lawyer an engineer but
it's the inspiration from football
players like yourself ronaldo and others
is exceptional
and then of course we've got one of the
most successful
women coaches in the world who's won the
world cup twice
uh america is doing very very well i'm
told that at some stage the man will
become as good as the woman but you know
the women are
leaps and bounds ahead and we wish the
man all of the best and we're very proud
of jill ellis and the work she does and
of course
you can clap hands for it's fine
wonderful
work in being the spokesperson very
eloquent very inspiring and the good
work that you've done as
the leader of the local organizing
committee we're very proud and you've
done good work and we're going to be
qatar is going to
show the world
not only the beauty of the hearts of the
qatar people but also the power of
football to unite people from different
backgrounds different continents because
the world needs unity eduard mandy i had
to give him the
the
gold medal for being champions of africa
and made us so proud he's the currently
the best goalkeeper in the world
and uh inspires hundreds of millions of
young people
of course many of them from africa but
worldwide and i did comment and say of
course you know as the president of
africa i want him to do well
but and we want all african teams and
all teams to do well throughout the
world we also want qatar to keep on
doing well so
you know follow the rules and everything
and uh i wish you all of the best
arsene wenger
i don't need to say much of about us and
brilliant football brain but also an
incredible person
and his commitment to football
development and the role he plays in
fifa is outstanding i'm going to start
with yuji honey
you are the president of fifa
and fifa is the biggest
and the most
influential
sport
organization in the world
and
part of the issues today is to talk
about football as a force for good
football as a force for good the immense
positive contributions of football
and
and as i said earlier
the unique role of football to to unite
people different languages different
cultures different races
and
encourage young people tell us about
how you see
the the football world cup the qatar
showcasing of the best and the highest
level of competition of football in the
world
well thanks uh thanks patrice and and
let me first of all thank as well uh
professor schwab for
allowing for having a fifa and
the world of football here at the world
economic forum it is a great honor for
our 211 member countries more than the
united nations our over 300 million of
active players and billions of
football fans all over the world to be
represented here at this
very prestigious
stage
well
you know mandela was saying that sport
can change the world
that it can inspire that it unites
and definitely he was he was right with
that and football as the most popular
sport
in the world has a unique reach the last
world cup was
watched by four billion people the last
women's world cup by 1.2 billion people
this world cup in qatar will be watched
by 5 billion people
way above half of the world population
and
[Applause]
all these people who follow and pursue
the same passion
they all feel in the same way and they
all know that football has this uniting
force and there are many examples in
history you speak about the world cup
let's look a little bit back 2002 japan
and and korea together jointly
organizing the first world cup in asia
in 2006 a united germany as well
welcoming the worlds as they were saying
amongst friends this was
their slogan
well south africa 2010
united the whole of africa in pride of
organizing
such
an incredible event
the world cup in a few months in in
qatar the first world cup in the arab
world will be the best best world cup
ever united in the arab world but
uniting as well the entire world in the
arab world which is so important and his
highness the emir mentioned it is so
important in this particular
times and even if we look
forward a couple of years ago
when there were discussions about
building a wall
between mexico and the united states
well mexico and the united states
together and together with canada
decided to work jointly to put a bit to
organize jointly the world cup
this is only football can do it and
football can do much more i would just
like to mention
gender equality empowerment
of women and the role of football in
this respect which is which is
quite unique thanks to the
perseverance that was mentioned earlier
as well
we managed to obtain for example that
women in iran
can go in the 10 football games this was
not the case for 40 years now will this
change
anything
well
maybe maybe not but many many women in
iran are happy
about that in sudan in saudi arabia
there are women league there are women
national team now playing football um
as well as whereas
sheikh mohammed here
thanks to the help of qatar we have been
able
or they have been able and we have
contributed a little bit to evacuate
many people from afghanistan including a
lot of women who are playing football in
afghanistan and these kind of messages
are are incredible and you said it
football unites when the national team
is playing and we'll see it at the world
cup the whole country is behind that
national team i always remember
george well one of the best players in
the world
who now is the head of state of liberia
saying that when they were playing with
the national team of liberia and there
was war uh you know the war would even
stop and people would unite behind the
callers of the national team football is
definitely a force for good thank you so
much gianni
okay if you are just joining us that was
fifa boss uh gianni infantino uh
speaking there at the world economic
forum in davos uh hosting a panel there
of uh some top uh sports uh talents
involved in the fifa world cup that is
coming up in qatar later this year we're
joined now by our sports presenter andy
richardson he's here with me in the
studio andy uh so clearly the message uh
from that panel there is that uh sport
is a unifying force football in
particular is a unifying force and in in
this time of uh political insecurity the
troubles we're seeing in the world
sports can bring people together
i think there's a really valid point to
be made there about um the impact this
tournament will have post covered 19 in
the coronavirus we've seen so many major
sporting events in the last couple of
years be played behind
closed doors with limited um limited
numbers of fans and i think you know
this world cup will hopefully be the
first big tournament in two or three
years where a huge number of fans from
different countries will be able to
congregate and unify together obviously
there are limits to sports power as a
unifying force let's not forget that
although mr infantino there the
president of fifa listed uh some of the
some of the positives have come from
previous world cups the last world cup
in 2018 uh was in russia and you know
countries do also use sport as a means
to to project the best possible image of
that country uh to the world it's a good
way of doing that we heard earlier um
from the world economic forum and and
let's just think of the name this is
much more than just a sporting event the
world cup we've got uh people at the
world economic forum discussing it uh
the emir of qatar was talking talking
earlier and he did say
that he feels both the bid which was
successful in 2010 and the region
generally for decades has faced a lot of
unfair discrimination and clear bias as
as they would see it
from certain sections of the media ever
since uh this bid was won that perhaps
there's this conception that the middle
east but qatar
doesn't have the right uh to host a
world cup and what what he's hoping and
what i think most of the organizers and
people who live here in qatar are hoping
is that if people do come to qatar do
enjoy this world cup that some of those
preconceptions about qatar will be
broken down and that there will be
tangible legacies uh maybe the
advancements of of workers rights that
have been accelerated by the spotlight
that's been shown in this country and
they've been accelerated because of uh
some of the the media coverage around
the world that will be a meaningful
legacy once once the football is
finished yeah it was a very interesting
speech uh by the emir earlier where he
talked about
uh qatar's not perfect no country is
perfect in fact and the main thing is
they are learning from their mistakes
and changing with it
um andy richardson our sports presenter
here in the studio thank you so much